e o doido é
a junina menininha sereia do mundo ela
vem cá louça ela vem ela vem ela vem
[Música]
talvez acabou chama a mãe da
me chama cala a boca gente todas aonde
na mini tomar
é uma menininha ela vem para ela ela vem
belos ela vem ela vem salve a mãe d'água
salve salve a cabocla todas as aldeias
tava mandar água chama sereia chamas
cabocla eu não sou daqui marinheiro só
meu amor marinheiro só
e sábado eu não sou daqui marinheiro só
eu não tenho amor eu sou da bahia
[Música]
salvador marinheiro marinheiro foi lá
vem lá vem maria vem
é todo de branco cancelar bonezinho o
marinheiro marinheiro quem te ensinou a
navegar ou foi o tombo do navio lavei
como é
e o seu bonezinho todo de branco consigo
sim
o marinheiro karina marinheiro só não
vai navegar o tombo do navio e
e lá vem lá vem maria você
oi amorzinho na vila vez como ele vem
faceiro todo de branco marinheiro só com
seu do brasil
e aí